é não sei quanto a vocês mas eu gosto
muito fico muito intrigada quando eu
vejo
de um lado a gente vivendo nessa era de
altíssima tecnologia digital e de
repente a gente também olha para a
tecnologia humana ea gente vê o quanto a
gente foi fundo nisso e fico muito feliz
de ver essas coisas integrando o que a
gente vai falar aqui hoje eu trouxe pra
vocês acham em um convite aberto na
verdade se eu conseguir com essa fala é
convocar vocês enfim despertar vocês pra
irem dar uma olhada em todos esses novos
estudos em todas esses novos projetos
que estão trabalhando a felicidade
enquanto uma coisa um pouco mais próximo
em um pouco mais praticável é que
depende cada vez mais de cada um de nós
e vou sair vou ficar feliz
então comece com uma pergunta mesmo
recebendo jornalista né jornalistas
adoram fazer perguntas ao que já falou
isso aqui agora
então que tal a gente focar no projeto
no positivo e praticar a felicidade
bom eu acredito muito que a gente vive
não tenho esse tempo é tempo de
construir né é construir o que né eu
fico ou converso muito com os meus pais
que são de uma outra geração e eles
ficam bastante surpreso se eles falam
nossa cara eu fico impressionada com
você com seus amigos com as pessoas
dessas gerações eu tenho um irmão que é
dez anos mais novo
outra geração também eles falam cara
parece que vocês querem sim construir
alguma coisa nova mas diferente da gente
que achava que a gente ia construir
primeiro conceitualmente o novo modelo
vocês não estão tão preocupados assim
construir alguma coisa que esteja
conceitualmente correta para depois a
gente mudar enquanto sociedade
eu vejo vocês na prática enfim quase que
o que a gente juntos resolveu chamar de
a gente está fazendo grande upload do
sistema que a gente vive e se a gente a
partir disso vai chegar um novo sistema
a gente não sabe quem sabe né então a
gente fala das mesmas coisas que a gente
sempre falou transporte política a gente
fala de economia a gente fala de consumo
mas a gente parece que tá querendo
colocar adjetivos nessas coisas todas né
então a gente não fala de quando a gente
fala de economia compartilhada economia
colaborativa
quando a gente fala de política só de
política aberta político em rede web
democracia enfim nem outras é termos que
surgem
é e aí eu acho que é bastante
interessante esse momento de upload é
que a gente tá tá fazendo eu convido
você para uma reflexão antes de começar
a falar do que o que eu mais quero falar
aqui pra vocês que têm a ver com a
felicidade com que eu faço no meu dia a
dia que é assim vamos parar para pensar
quanto tempo a gente leva hoje pra
construir um prédio tem bastante
engenheiro aqui na platéia quanto tempo
a gente leva para destruir
parece que construir é trabalhoso né eu
acho que se a gente fizer junto vai
ficar mais fácil eu trouxe um exemplo de
uma coisa que eu gosto muito e vou
mostrar um vídeo rápido pra vocês que é
que a construção por um lado ela é
trabalhosa
por outro se a gente usa a nossa
inteligência ea gente está toda essa
tecnologia a nosso favor
a coisa funciona feliz e poder me ajudar
hum
ah
vamos lá que já conhecia esse projeto a
casa alguém já tinha visto já tinha
ouvido falar do projeto está quase
finalizado ele hoje é suportado pela
nasa e realmente assim vamos construir
casas in the free the print em 24 horas
nessa incrível como a gente consegue
realmente usa a tecnologia para as
nossas necessidades humanas é bom
meu assunto é altíssima tecnologia
humana como já deu pra perceber vem
estudando um assunto que apesar de aqui
no brasil ainda não sei algo muito
conhecido que já ouviu falar da
psicologia positiva legal em algumas
pessoas que bom
lá nos estados unidos já é tipo há três
anos consecutivos a aula mais procurada
de harvard assim ele fica dentro de um
curso de saúde públicas e agora já está
se tornando o instituto por si só de
tanto que as pessoas estão interessadas
nesse assunto bom mas que essa tal
psicologia do positivo né
ela nasce na década de 90 para estudar a
aceco medicina preventiva né é e
psicólogos da psicologia positiva dizem
olha parece que a psicologia tradicional
por ter emergido dentro de uma cultura
de guerra ela acabou se dedicando muito
aos estudos das doenças mentais e aí a
gente parte do princípio de que todo ser
humano doente isso não é verdade
então eles começaram várias pesquisas e
isso já vem mostrando alguns resultados
de que se a gente entende que a gente
tem que fofocar nas nossas vocações a
descoberta das vocações e na no
desenvolvimento das nossas habilidades
da nossa força de vontade
uma grande mágica pode acontecer aí eles
acreditam que isso é um trabalho muito
forte de realmente a gente migrado uma
cultura de guerra para uma cultura de
paz e que essa transformação acontece
primeiro de dentro do indivíduo como
todas as grandes transformações para
depois a gente mudar a nossa relação com
os outros ea relação com todo né é e aí
que eles chegaram numa questão muito
interessante que eles chamam de a
fórmula da felicidade e parece que essa
fórmula da felicidade diz que tem 50% de
disso da nossa felicidade vem de
características genéticas
eles fizeram testes com quatro de 45 mil
gêmeos univitelinos eles descobriram que
tem uma grande parcela da felicidade que
está relacionada a questões genéticas é
e se por um lado a gente pode pensar
puxa 50% da minha felicidade está e eu
não posso e não posso trabalhar com ela
não na verdade não é isso
por um lado é isso nos ajuda porque toda
hora que a gente está triste a gente
tende a ter um áudio genético também que
nos traz pra uma uma tranqüilidade enfim
nos tira dessa dessa zona de tristeza e
nos devolve para uma zona de conforto
digamos assim
agora o mais legal dessa forma da
felicidade é que o que a gente chama o
que eles chamam de condições de vida né
que é aquilo que a gente mais acredita
que é onde está a nossa felicidade que
por exemplo em frente à casa do solteiro
se a gente está magro corpo se a gente é
rico ou pobre é aquilo que a gente mais
acha que determina a nossa felicidade é
o que menos determina isso aqui na
fórmula da felicidade parece está em 10%
e 40% da nossa felicidade parece estar
no que estão chamando também de atitudes
intencionais e atitudes voluntárias que
tudo aquilo que a gente pode fazer o que
está na nossa mão no dia a dia nas
escolhas cotidianas e que a gente pode
enfim a partir disso ser mais feliz e
praticar mais a felicidade
são coisas do tipo eles chegaram num
conceito que chama flow aqui que é o
flor é quando você está tão presente no
momento você está tão presente naquilo
que está fazendo que você entra num
estado de satisfação e felicidade que é
extremamente especial
a gente vê isso muito por exemplo de um
esportista muito bom tá lá enfim num
momento em que ele está competindo que
ele pague ganhando e aquilo é fácil a
gente perceber que está no fogo né de
portos e na dirigindo o carro dele né o
saae bolt correndo os 100 metros rasos é
um pianista incrível quando ele está
tocando piano e ainda parece que tudo em
volta se apaga ele está ali conectado
presente no momento ele está neste
momento de flor
sim quando a gente olha precise preciso
extremos né é a gente entende o que é o
fluxo que a gente precisa saber também
que a gente consegue ter flow quando já
estava lavando louça na nossa casa
quando a gente está num papo com os
amigos que está incrível e ninguém quer
ir pra casa e já são meia noite
então tem muita coisa que acontece no
nosso dia a dia e que a gente consegue
através da desses momentos entrar em
flor
e é justamente isso que a gente deveria
perseguir é justamente isso que a gente
deveria fazer no nosso dia a dia
bom aqui tem um a uma coisa bacana aqui
essa pessoa
ele é o pai da psicologia positiva é
chamado o nome dele é martin seligman
ele coordena todo esse tem que teclar em
harvard está abrindo cursos pelo mundo
afora
aqui é um outro professor ele chama dan
gilbert também é desse grupo d depois
ficou longos que estão fazendo todas
essas pesquisas dentro da psicologia
positiva ele escrevesse esse livro que
chama tropeçando na felicidade e aqui
tem um ponto muito legal para a gente
prestar atenção que chama bastante
atenção que é o seguinte i am
ele descobriu que o que mais impede a
nossa felicidade é uma coisa que se
chama adaptação hedônica é aquilo que a
gente ele disse que a gente
autossabotagem nossa felicidade
ele fez algumas pesquisas trabalhando
com alguns americanos é uma amostragem
grande até e aí era uma pesquisa toda
fundamentada em escolhas desde escolhas
pequenas o que você vai pedir o almoço
até escolhas de vida como é que você vai
trocar sua profissão e aonde você vai
morar e que vai fazer profissionalmente
e ele descobriu que as pessoas todos nós
a gente tem de a sonhar com alguma coisa
que esteja ao nosso alcance para uma
insegurança da gente dá um passo muito
longo e muito longe porque a gente
prefere ter uma meia felicidade do que
arriscar uma super felicidade e aí que
ele fala que a gente está tropeçando na
nossa felicidade de que a gente precisa
conhecer mais esses processos olhar para
essas pesquisas entender um pouco mais a
felicidade pra gente não chegar nesse
ponto em que de alguma forma a gente ele
fala é de mediocridade no sentido
literal da palavra de mediano mesmo
ele quer que a gente sair mais e essa
história da felicidade gente am
ela parte do ponto do indivíduo mas ela
se expande anos e certamente já ouviram
falar que tem um monte de gente já
pensando em como tornar a felicidade um
grande índice é pra gente aplicar em
países
lá no botão já tem é o que eles chamam
de fibra e felicidade
interna bruta alguém já ouviu falar do
filme também há mais gente bacana é essa
moça aqui tá na foto ali em cima
ela se chama seus remédios ela é uma
cientista de harvard também mas ela
monja é ela tá aqui no brasil numa
cidade chamada porangaba pertinho de são
paulo aqui vocês quiserem visitar ela dá
um curso de psicologia
mas o legal é que ela trabalhou no grupo
de pensadores e de pessoas que
resolveram instalar né
o fib lá no botão tam e uma das coisas
interessantes da pesquisa desse grupo de
pessoas que estavam envolvidas nessa
implementação desse indicador novo esse
gráfico aqui o gráfico diz mostra a
evolução do pib
naquela linha verde que sobe ali ea
evolução do índice de satisfação da
população americana de 1973 até 2000 e
aí que eles perceberam que na verdade
não existe uma correlação entre o
dinheiro que a gente ganha né do
desenvolvimento econômico da sociedade
eo aumento do índice de satisfação de
ver e de felicidade
existe sim até um certo ponto eles até
chegar a um número na na pesquisa acho
que se eu não me engano são seis mil
dólares para uma família de quatro
pessoas
é o máximo de que o dinheiro pode fazer
para a sua felicidade de termos assim né
depois disso já não não é aí que mora o
segredo da felicidade não é aí que a
gente consegue fica mais feliz
bom eu tive a oportunidade no começo
deste ano e lá no botão conversar com o
pessoal que faz parte desse projeto
inglês
o fib é que a felicidade interna bruta
se chama dia leite que gross national
happiness e eu fui conversar com o
pessoal do dia na psique o gross
national happiness commission que é o
pessoal que operacionalize essa história
eu achei extremamente interessante a
gente tem muito a aprender porque assim
eles rodam uma pesquisa que no nosso ver
é um censo a cada dois anos ea partir
desse censo traz alguns indicadores
interessantes assim que eu falei nossa
olha só incide vitalidade comunitária
eles medem o quanto você está feliz
coexistindo com aquela população que
mora ao redor de você no seu mesmo
bairro na sua rua e também o como você
desde que você faz uso do seu tempo seu
tempo uma moeda muito importante hoje em
dia acho que todo mundo sabe também
então eles estão indo em questões
bastante profundas bom a partir disso é
que lá todo mundo feliz né
a partir disso eles eles enfim conseguem
mensurar né enfim captar onde é que
estão os problemas do país digamos assim
em relação à a felicidade e aí eles
tomam decisões em relação a isso todas
as leis do país elas passam pela pela
comissão da do índice de felicidade
então nenhuma lei no país não pode ser é
frangueiro digamos assim não pode tá é
contra ou não jogar a favor da política
de felicidade do país
e aí eles tomaram decisões como a
meditação nas escolas primárias pelo
país todo porque eles entendem meditação
como uma medicina preventiva também é
uma prevenção a stress ea outras doenças
é um país budista então também eles têm
uma outra compreensão aí dá da meditação
e também lá é um país que tem muito
minério então tem muita mineradora
inclusive de outros países operando ano
eles têm por exemplo uma uma diretriz
que veio dessa comissão que todas as
mineradoras a partida em que elas ganham
uma licitação pra funcionar para alterar
naquele determinado lugar o projeto já
tem que vir com a revitalização do lugar
lugar quando a mineradora sair de lá
o lugar tem que estar melhor do que
estava quando ela encontrou uma
interessante é muito bacana e aí que
todas essas pesquisas parecem chegar não
poderia ficar aqui dois dias falando das
pesquisas e compra o francês que fim eu
sou muito apaixonada por isso mesmo
estou cada vez mais
mas as pesquisas parecem mostrar que um
dos segredos da felicidade parece ser
isso que a gente chama de senso de
comunidade e aí tem um professor que é
também de harvard
uma pena que ainda tudo muito
concentrado lá enfim tudo tentando
juntar uma turma pra ver se a gente
consegue trazer pra cá espalhar pelo
mundo isso mas parece que vivem em
comunidade faz a gente focar naquilo que
a gente tem pra compartilhar mais do que
naquilo que a gente não tem
parece que a gente não tem tempo para
pensar no que está ruim no que está
errado
porque a gente tá ali na comunidade a
gente tem um senso de comunidade apurado
e aí a gente tá pensando que eu tenho de
melhor que eu posso trocar e o que eu
tenho de melhor que eu posso fazer pra
isso pra todo mundo que está aqui
isso aqui é um projeto muito bacana
também americano que chama de rapinas
projeto é de uma moça chamada grátis
robin se vocês quiserem dar uma olhada
tem site tem aquele modelo americano de
ser neto kit pra prática da felicidade
ah eu enfim mergulhei nessa um pouquinho
tentando fazer o meu projecto que ela
fez ela desenha um projeto de felicidade
para ela de 12 meses
plano esse ano eu vou conseguir ser mais
feliz e aí no primeiro mês ela traçou
objetivos é no primeiro mês no segundo
ou terceiro enfim até o último grande
lance é aqui no segundo mês ela
acumulava o que ela tinha feito e que
ela tinha percebido que tinha sido bom
pra ela no primeiro e agregava porque
ela tinha traçado como meta no segundo e
no terceiro e assim por diante
o 12º mês ela viu que funcionava para
ela que não funcionava
agora uma coisa muito legal aqui no
primeiro mês ela resolveu se esvaziar o
flu antes de dar qualquer passo a gente
eu vivo no momento a gente vive numa era
de enfim super informação e tantas
coisas eu vou me basear e ela começou a
pensar a focar o que é se esvaziar
então esses vazio desde marcar -
reuniões desde meditar mais porque o
esvaziamento da mente desde se livrar de
todas as roupas do guarda roupa que ela
achava que já não tinham fazia mais
sentido para ela
então tá ela teve uma compreensão assim
de cada uma das metas que ela colocava
ao longo dos meses era uma ela fazia um
mergulho profundo para tentar entender
em diversos níveis o que aquilo
significava para ela o resultado foi
muito bacana tem bastante gente
praticando e é isso que eu queria chegar
na verdade né porque acho que durante
muito tempo assim como eu falei lá no
começo de gerações passadas pelo menos
meus pais me dizem a gente troca
bastante essa questão da gente querer
conceber alguma coisa né e parece que
antes da gente fazer a coisa acho que a
gente tem divertido isso é e aí eu acho
que a felicidade também por muito tempo
ela ficou num plano ideal que é a
felicidade no fundo não é gente
o bacana de todas as toda essa nova
ciência da irônica que estuda felicidade
todas essas experiências é não se
aproximar desse termo não entender que
isso significa que a gente quer tanto
e aí que eu acho bacana que é praticar a
felicidade né que a gente deve pensar a
felicidade como uma qualidade que a
gente pode desenvolver assim como
tolerância e empatia e tantas outras
coisas uma coisa bacana também no nível
do da felicidade não individual mas de
grupo na de nação existe um ranking dos
países mais felizes do mundo ea
dinamarca está no topo dele e não
curiosamente a dinamarca país que mais
tem como raulzinho do mundo com house é
um conceito são casas compartilhadas e
quando você tem o seu espaço privado mas
aquela construção abriga várias famílias
e vai enfim várias várias pessoas e as
áreas são compartilhadas na então a
gente lava as roupas onde a gente come e
assim vai
chama cristiana essa a maior causa da
dinamarca chama christian e cristiano é
super curioso porque as pessoas que
moram lá e são mais ou menos vale chega
duas mil pessoas
elas fazem rodízio de quem busca as
crianças na escola de quem faz o almoço
naquele dia ou quem faz o jantar e aí
sim você pode passar dois meses sem
fazer e na hora que você faz o que eles
falam em um filme que mostra isso ele se
chama e o bacana é que quando você vai
fazer se está concentrado naquilo que
está achando incrível fazer aquilo que
não é que caiu naquele lugar comum de
que todo dia você tem que cozinhar ou
todo dia você tem que lavar e aí aquele
momento que antes era digamos assim vai
um pé no saco ver uma coisa bacana e o
país que está enfim na no bottom né em
baixo no ranking de felicidade é o japão
o japão eles até criaram o termo chama
monte o que é que aconteceu um fenômeno
no japão que as pessoas estão morrendo
de tanto trabalhar
então assim tem fotos desse fenômeno de
executivos nos bancos das praças ou nos
bancos da do metrô
simplesmente eles apagam o coração apaga
de tanto que estão trabalhando ou
jogando videogame e também tem os jovens
sobre isso e mas ao mesmo tempo lá no
japão um país extremamente interessante
é que tenha uma ilha no japão chamar o
que na água que é considerado um dos
lugares mais felizes do mundo junto com
a dinamarca o quintal onde vivem as
pessoas mais
é assim que se fala longevas nessas
pessoas mais velhas do mundo então tem
uma comunidade de senhores e senhoras
large 115 e 125 anos
e aí quando você vai ver os caras só
sorri
eles são eles dizem que eles atribuem
quando se pergunta para eles então sim o
que você atribui essa felicidade porque
a longevidade é uma das coisas que
compõem vai ruins e felicidade
a expectativa de vida alta e eles falam
olha eu acho que é porque a gente é uma
grande família a ilha inteira uma grande
família então volta para a questão do
senso de comunidade como talvez o
principal atributo de de conquista da
felicidade
bom você foi convidada para aqui agora
acho que é muito menos pelas minhas
pesquisas individuais digamos assim
disse sobre felicidade mas pelo projeto
que enfim desde 2009 2010 e coloquei no
mundo que é um portal de boas notícias
chamadas boas novas pontocom
na verdade as boas-novas nasceu baseado
em tudo isso que eu falei pra vocês
ele é um portal jornalístico ea gente
tem como foco é trabalhar e olhar as
coisas positivas pensando em uma
transformação maior que a gente pode
causar no mundo
a gente faz parte na verdade apesar de
sermos o primeiro e talvez o único
portal existem blogs coisas um pouco
menores a organizado aqui no brasil a
gente faz parte de um movimento global
que o movimento da mídia construtiva e
tem alguns expoentes por aí pra quem não
conhece alguém que já conhece as boas
novas e vai tá bom pra quem não conhece
as boas-novas falcão é e as pessoas me
perguntam muito que a boa notícia
agora x é aquela que tem foco na solução
não tem nada de óculos cor-de-rosa é o
foco na solução e naquilo que constrói a
gente tem um lema interno ano no
escritório que a gente fala que quem
critica muito não tem nem energia nem
tempo para construir algo novo então é
isso aí e as pessoas me perguntam muito
falar mas a boa notícia é o foco na
sustentabilidade é o foco sustentável
eu costumo dizer eu acho que a gente é
fruto dessa tal sustentabilidade porque
a sustentabilidade nada mais é do que
aquilo que estava falando no começo
todas as áreas da sociedade todas as
esferas todo mundo se repensando para
fazer aquilo que a gente sempre fez de
forma diferente mas eu acredito que a
gente trabalha mais com a felicidade do
que houve com a sustentabilidade porque
afinal a gente quer um futuro
sustentável
hoje
acho que é um futuro feliz quando a
gente fala uma criança você quer estudar
aqui até aula de física você quer ser
astronauta
eu acho que essa capacidade de sonhar
que a gente está querendo recuperar e
tem outro lema também que termina com
ele na verdade que é se não é divertido
não tem como ser sustentável
obrigada